Guten Tag, ich bin heute die zuständige Ärztin für Sie und möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, können Sie mir das einfach sagen.
Wie heißen Sie dann? Erst muss ich die persönlichen Daten aufnehmen von Ihnen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Magdalena Schmidt.
Magsa?
Magdalena Schmidt.
Schmit?
Magda, Lena, Schmidt. Können Sie bitte den Nachnamen und... Ist der Nachname Schmit?
Schmit ist der Nachname, mit Doppel-T am Ende.
Mit Doppel-T, okay. Und der Nachname... Der zweite Name ist...
Der Vorname ist ein bisschen länger, den Buchstab...
Der zweite Name ist Lena.
Magda Lena. Also gehört...
Zusammen.
Zwei Teile. M-A-G-D-A... M-A-G-D-A... L-E-N-A. Magda Lena.
Okay. Magda Lena Schmidt. Okay. Frau Schmidt.
Genau.
Ja. Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 56 und bin geboren am 11.06.1970.
1970. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 Meter und wiege 79 Kilo.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Dr. Kröger.
Okay. Was führt Sie heute zu uns, Frau Schmidt?
Ja. Also, ich habe mit einmal solche Schmerzen und so eine Schwellung in meinem rechten Arm.
Und überwiegend im Oberarm, aber das geht auch runter.
Ich habe das Gefühl, hier oben ist am stärksten.
Aber das geht bis zur Hand, dass das alles ein bisschen geschwollen ist.
Und das wird immer mehr. Und das ist auch...
Also, es ist nicht nur dick, es ist auch warm. Es fühlt sich warmer, es ist so ein bisschen gerötet.
Und ich habe so das Gefühl, dass das so prall ist, dass ich da so Spannung drauf habe.
Und deswegen habe ich das Gefühl, ich kann diesen rechten Arm gar nicht bewegen.
Und der fühlt sich auch so schwer an.
Ich unterstütze ihn also immer mit der anderen Hand.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss den eigentlich immer tragen, weil runterhängen ganz schlecht ist.
Okay. Am rechten Arm haben Sie die Schmerzen, besonders im Oberarm.
Und auch eine Schwellung. Und Sie haben eine Wärmung, eine Wärmegewürz.
Überwärmung, ja. Also, es ist einfach wärmer als der andere.
Und Krötung, Spannung im Oberarm auch unten?
Ja, also ich würde sagen, die Hauptspannung ist im Oberarm.
Aber ich merke, dass eben auch so die Finger so verschwollen sind.
Die Finger sind auch verschwollen.
Okay, verschwollen. Ja. Und seit wann haben Sie dann diese Beschwerden?
Ja, das hat vor ein paar Tagen angefangen. Aber es wird halt immer mehr.
Und erst habe ich gedacht, naja gut, es wird schon wieder weggehen.
Aber dadurch, dass das immer schlimmer geworden ist, habe ich gedacht, ich muss mich jetzt doch mal bei Ihnen vorstellen.
Okay. Ist es plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ja, also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, dass es dann Auslöser gab oder so.
Sie haben keinen Auslöser bemerkt? Ja.
Haben Sie eine Verstärkung oder Linderung-Tauktau bemerkt für diese Schmerzen und für die Eiläpp-Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, wie gesagt, wenn der Arm runterhängt, dass es dann ganz unangenehm ist,
dann werden die Schmerzen mehr und dann habe ich so das Gefühl, ich kann den kaum tragen.
Ja, Linderung. Also wenn ich im Bett liege zum Beispiel, mache ich mir jetzt einen Kissen darunter.
Und dann kann ich es eigentlich ganz gut aushalten.
Und ich habe versucht, schon mal mit einem kalten Waschlappen das ein bisschen zu kühlen. Das war ganz angenehm.
Das hat auch gut. Ja, hat gut getan.
Kälte. Okay. Und diese Schmerzen? Können Sie mir diese Schmerzen beschreiben? Sind Sie dumpf, stechend?
Nee, stechend nicht. Also ich würde sagen, ich habe so ein Druckgefühl da drauf.
Druckgefühl? Und sind Sie dauerhaft oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Nee, also weggehen tun die nicht. Das stimmt. Und sie werden immer mehr.
Okay. Und wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen, wenn wir eine Schmerzkalle haben, von 1 bis 10?
Wenn 1 sehr leichte und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen bedeuten?
Also sehr stark. Man hat schlimmere Sachen erlebt, würde ich sagen.
Aber ich denke, vielleicht über die Hälfte, so 6.
Haben Sie jetzt auch Schmerzen? Ja. Sie haben mir gesagt, Sie sind immer da.
Also dieser ständige Druck ist da drin. Ständiger Druck.
Okay. Hatten Sie einen Unfall oder eine Verletzung gehabt?
Nee, eben nicht. Also es wundert mich halt.
Keinen Unfall, keine Verletzung.
Okay. Und haben Sie etwas eingenommen für diese Beschwerden?
Nein, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich dagegen einnehmen soll.
Sie sind erst mal zu uns gekommen, oder?
Jaja, ich bin sofort zu Ihnen gekommen. Also nach 3 Tagen immer mehr wurde.
Okay, das haben Sie gut gemacht. Und haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber ich denke, Fieberig fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Fieberig nicht. Nachtschweiß, Schüttelfrost?
Nee, das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Nachtschweiß, Schüttelfrost auch nicht.
Okay. Wie ist die Appetit? Hat sich das geändert?
Na ja, in den 3 Tagen hat sich das nicht geändert, würde ich sagen.
Bei der Wärme ist man sowieso nicht so gut, aber man hat nicht solchen Hunger.
Aber ich würde sagen, mein Appetit ist unverändert.
Ich fühle mich eigentlich auch nicht krank oder so, sondern das ist eben nur dieser Arm, der mir jetzt diese Beschwerden macht.
Okay. Und abgenommen, zugenommen haben Sie auch nicht, denke ich, oder?
Halt nicht, ist mein Gewicht ziemlich stabil seit langer Zeit.
Gewicht stabil? Ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Moment? Gewicht stabil, muss ich jetzt noch schreiben.
Wurde es Ihnen schlecht oder müssten Sie erbrechen?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich habe noch nicht so viel Armlift, sonst habe ich noch.
Ja, okay. Ich verstehe. Diese Fragen muss ich stellen, dass wir nichts vergessen, um die richtige Diagnose zu feststellen.
Okay, deswegen muss ich diese alle Fragen stellen.
Und haben Sie Wasserlassenstuhlka-Probleme?
Zum Glück nicht.
Okay, Wasserlassenstuhlka ist alles normal. Okay. Der Schlaf ist auch normal, oder?
Na ja, die beiden letzten Nächte habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen, weil mich das schon gestört hat eigentlich.
Und weil ich komisch gelegen habe, um den Arm da so hoch zu lagern. Das war nicht so wie immer und da habe ich jetzt nicht so gut geschlafen.
Okay. Jetzt muss ich an Ihren Vorkranken fragen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorkranken, von denen ich wissen sollte, Bluthoffdruck, Zuckerkrankheit oder hohe Blutfettwerke?
Da ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck. Das hat man vor 14 Jahren festgestellt.
Und da hat man auch festgestellt, dass der Cholesterinwert ein bisschen hoch ist.
Aber wichtig ist wahrscheinlich, dass ich eben vor 14 Jahren eine Brust-OP hatte wegen Brustkrebs.
Vor 14 Jahren hatten Sie eine Brustkrebs-OP gehabt.
Ja, genau. Das ist operativ entfernt worden und ist also ganz kurz nachgestrahlt worden.
Aber es ist jetzt immer kontrolliert worden und war bisher immer gut.
Immer gut. Lassen Sie sich immer noch kontrollieren.
Ich gehe jetzt noch einmal im Jahr zum Gynäkologen.
Diese engen Kontrollen sind jetzt abgeschlossen.
Aber jedes Jahr gehen Sie. Bis jetzt war alles normal.
Okay. Und außer das Bluthoffdruck und die Hyperkolistinämie, haben Sie noch eine andere Krankheit?
Vor einem Jahr habe ich noch eine neue Hüfte links bekommen.
Vor einem Jahr? Eine Prothese?
Ja, eine Hüftprothese.
Warum?
Ich hatte also stärkste Schmerzen und konnte also nicht mehr schmerzfrei laufen.
Und dann hat man sich entschieden, das schon zu machen.
Okay. Vor einem Jahr.
Und außer dieser Blutoperation hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, das reicht mir auch vollkommen, muss ich sagen.
Okay, das ist gut. Nehmen Sie Medikamente ein?
Ja, gegen den Bluthoffdruck nehme ich Konkour 5 und Diavan.
Konkour 5 und Diavan.
Wissen Sie die Diavan-Dosierung?
160, meine ich, steht da drauf.
Und dann nehme ich morgens eine und Konkour 5 nehme ich auch morgens eine.
Konkour 5, eine morgens, Diavan auch eine morgens.
Und sonst nehmen Sie nichts ein, oder?
Ja, also ich habe noch so eine Allergie auf Blütenpollen.
Da kriege ich im Frühling häufig Heuschnupfen und dann tränen mir die Augen.
Und da nehme ich dann, wenn das schlimm ist, wenn die Augen ganz doll tränen
und wenn das alles so verschwollen ist, dann nehme ich noch Teterizin.
Teterizin, bei Bedarf.
Genau, bei Bedarf.
Teterizin.
Okay, haben Sie auch eine Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, also gerade diese Pollen-Allergie, das habe ich.
Aber sonst habe ich eigentlich wirklich jetzt nicht.
Okay. Rauchen Sie, Frau Schmidt?
Nein, also geraumt habe ich tatsächlich noch nie.
Oh, das ist ein sehr guter Vorteil für die Gesundheit.
Sie haben nie geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also gelegentlich, wenn sich das ergibt, wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt
oder zu einem sehr guten Essen, wenn man mal ausgeht
oder auch wenn man eingeladen ist.
Also hin und wieder trinke ich schon Alkohol, ja.
Was? Wein oder?
Ja, Wein oder ja, jetzt im Sommer, wenn es so warm ist,
trinke ich auch gerne mal ein großes Bier.
Okay, Wein und Weinbier.
Ja, jetzt muss ich eine routinmäßige Frage stellen.
Nehmen Sie das bitte nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen ein?
Nein, also außer den Medikamenten, die ich so regelmäßig einnehme,
Drogen muss ich nicht einnehmen, nein.
Okay, ja, ich denke schon auch.
Und ich muss ein paar Fragen an Ihre Familie stellen.
Sind Ihre Mutter und Ihr Vater gesund?
Mein Vater lebt schon gar nicht mehr.
Der hatte sehr früh einen Herzinfarkt.
Und der ist also schon lange verstorben.
Und meine Mutter...
Mein Herz ist beileid, ja. Wie alt war er, als er gestorben ist?
Ach, das ist schon so ewig lange her.
Der war noch keine 60. Der ist sehr jung gestorben.
Okay, mein Herz ist beileid.
Und meine Mutter, die ist natürlich jetzt auch schon nicht mehr so jung,
aber die hat auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, das weiß ich.
Da muss sie auch irgendwelche Medikamente einnehmen.
Und die hatte auch eine Hüftgelenksprothese vor Jahren schon.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich das von ihr geerbt, dass die das Gelenke nicht gut sind.
Okay, das könnte sein, ja.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder und eine Schwester.
Oder ich hatte einen Bruder und eine Schwester.
Mein Bruder ist tatsächlich auch sehr früh verstorben.
Der war ein paar Jahre älter als ich.
Und der hatte, genau wie mein Vater, auch einen Herzinfarkt.
Also, die Männer leben nicht lange in unserer Familie.
Mein Herz ist beileid, ja.
Und meine Schwester, ja, auch da gibt es diese familiäre Geschichte.
Die ist ein bisschen jünger als ich.
Und da hat man vor einem Jahr dann eben Brustkrebs festgestellt.
Hat man natürlich auch genau geguckt, weil ich erkrankt war und so.
Und ja, bei ihr hat man es dann vor einem Jahr festgestellt,
aber sie ist auch operiert und behandelt und es scheint ihr gut zu wehen.
Oh ja, okay.
Vor einem Jahr, Brustkrebs, okay, verstehe.
Und jetzt muss ich...
Ja, treiben Sie Sport?
Herr Schmidt, er fährt mit.
Nicht so wirklich viel.
Also, ich fahre gerne mit dem Fahrrad.
Und im Sommer gehe ich auch mal schwimmen.
Aber dass ich jetzt so der große Sportkrieg bin, kann ich nicht behaupten.
Ab und zu fahren Sie Fahrrad und gehen Sie manchmal zum Schwimmen.
Ich verstehe. Haben Sie eine Reise gemacht in der letzten Zeit?
Hatten Sie eine Reise?
Nee, der Sommerurlaub steht noch bevor.
Sie waren nicht immer aus dem Land, okay.
Und Ihre Impfung, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Meinen Sie gegen Covid?
Gegen Covid, gegen die Kinderkrankheiten oder...
Kinderkrankheiten, das war schon lange her.
Und Covid, hm...
Ja, da habe ich also wenigstens 4 Impfungen bekommen.
Und was ich tatsächlich auch immer mache, das ist die Grippeimpfung.
Das lasse ich mir jedes Jahr rechtzeitig geben.
Sehr gut, okay.
Ich habe vorhin vergessen, hatten Sie einen Secondbiss?
Oder irgendwo irgendwie einen Insektbiss gehabt in der letzten Zeit?
Also...
An dem Arm?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Also da hat nichts gejuckt.
Und ich habe also jetzt auch nicht so viel im Garten gearbeitet die letzte Zeit.
Okay, okay.
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Reiseverkehrskauffrau.
Arbeite also im Reisebüro.
Und ich habe keine volle Stelle mehr, aber meine Arbeit macht mir viel Spaß.
Sehr gut, das ist gut zu hören.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß. Die sind aus dem Haus alle Kinder.
Ja, aber die sind okay, gesunde. Zwei gesunde Kinder.
Sie leben mit Ihrem Mann?
Ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen, genau.
Ja, ich glaube, ich bin fertig mit meinem Zahn.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich möchte jetzt natürlich nur wissen, was mit dem Arm ist und was man dagegen tun kann.
Und wie lange das möglicherweise dauert.
Denn so kann ich ja nicht arbeiten.
Ich muss eigentlich ja viel am Computer arbeiten.
Und mit der rechten Hand bediene ich ja die Maus.
Und da kann ich also nicht gut arbeiten.
Ja, ich hoffe, wir finden eine Lösung.
Aber jetzt ist es noch zu früh.
Ich muss eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen, Blut abnehmen.
Und vielleicht ein paar bildgebende Verfahren müssen wir durchführen.
Und nach allen Ergebnissen können wir etwas sagen.
Und ich möchte auch mit dem Fall mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Und dann sage ich, dass wir eine Lösung für Sie finden.
Das hoffe ich doch sehr.
Das klingt aber gut. Danke schön.
Ja, bitte schön.
Ich weiß jetzt gerade die Diagnose.
Also wenn es unten...
Du könntest auch eine Benin-Krime...
Wir sind ja noch in der Diskussion.
Da sagen wir nichts jetzt.
Raúl Schmidt, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ist die Hautberührung empfindlich?
Ja, sie spannt ja. Insofern ist sie berührungsempfindlich.
Überwiegend im Oberarm?
Und hatten Sie eine Lymphödem nach dem Brustkrebs-OP?
Nein, damals war eigentlich keine Lymphödem.
Sie hatten keine Mal, ja? Danke.
Frau Schmidt, wann war der letzte Kontroll beim Frauenarzt?
Das ist ungefähr drei Monate her.
Ok, Sie haben gesagt, alles war in Ordnung.
Genau.
Ich möchte wissen, in welcher Zeit Brust Sie operiert wurden?
Vor 14 Jahren.
Ich möchte wissen, welche Seite?
Welche Seite?
Rechts oder links?
Auch rechts, ja.
Auch rechts, ok.
Alles klar.
Hat jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich wollte fragen, ob die Rötung scharf begrenzt ist oder allgemein gerötet?
Scharf begrenzt ist sie nicht. Das geht so über, würde ich sagen.
Und noch eine andere Frage.
Hatten Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Flugreise oder waren Sie lange im Mobil gewesen?
So einer?
Ich bin eigentlich immer viel auf den Beinen und eine lange Flugreise habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ok, alles klar.
Frau Schmidt, bitte, Emre Bey.
Ich war da auch. Sie können fragen.
Frau Schmidt, haben Sie Atemnot, Herzrasen, Brustschmerzen, Engegefühl?
Nein, sowas habe ich alles. Zum Glück nicht.
Mir tut nur der Arm weh.
Frau Schmidt, haben Sie Ihre rechte Arme in den letzten Tagen ein bisschen überlastet?
Sie haben viel Arbeit gemacht?
Ja, ich arbeite natürlich, aber eigentlich nicht mehr als sonst, würde ich sagen.
Sie legen diese rechten Arme auf den Tisch, ja?
Ich bin Rechtshänderin und habe die Computer-Maus auch rechts.
Wenn ich am Computer arbeite, brauche ich auch beide Hände.
Dann hat man diese typische Position, aber eigentlich habe ich einen guten Arbeitsplatz.
Ich habe also nicht den Garten umgegraben in den letzten Tagen.
Ich meine, wie ist Ihr Tisch? Ergonomisch oder nicht?
Eigentlich ist mein Arbeitsplatz so, dass ich da sehr gut arbeiten kann.
Circa wie viele Stunden müssen Sie sitzen?
Ich arbeite höchstens sechs Stunden.
Sechs Stunden, danke.
Gibt es weitere Fragen, die wir stellen müssen?
Strahlung?
Nein, Strahlung nicht nachgefragt.
Ob die Schmerzen ausstrahlen?
Ja, ausstrahlen, nicht verraten.
Das hat sie tatsächlich nicht gefragt.
Ich habe nur gesagt, die Schwellung strahlt bis in die Hand aus.
Aber die Schmerzen, das hat sie tatsächlich nicht gefragt.
Okay, Strahlen, die Schmerzen?
Oh Gott, jetzt. Die Schmerzen strahlen bis in den Unterarm rein, aber nicht irgendwo in eine andere Gegend.
Leiden Sie unter der Morgensteifigkeit oder noch genauer?
Nein, die Finger sind vor allen Dingen abends geschwollen.
Wenn ich die Hand nicht hochlage, dann schwellen die Finger an.
Aber diese typische Morgensteifigkeit ist nicht vorhanden.
Schmerzcharakter wurde gefragt oder nicht?
Ja, Schmerzcharakter wurde gefragt, sechs von zehn.
Der Charakter aufragt.
Schmerzcharakter, drückend, stehend?
Drückend, das habe ich auch gesagt. Er hat sie gefragt und habe ich angegeben.
Gibt es fehlende Anlehnisseile oder Fragen?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass irgendwas fehlt. Ich meine, sie hat vollständig gefragt.
Ja, leider konnte ich nicht vorstellen.
Alles klar. Was sie tatsächlich nicht gefragt hat, das ist Parastensin, also Taubheitsgefühl oder Kribbelparastensin oder sowas. Das hat sie nicht gefragt.
Genau. Okay, haben Sie Taubheitsgefühl?
Nein, hat sie nicht.
Ja, da habe ich selber nicht so richtig gute Angaben, deswegen musste ich das so ein bisschen improvisieren.
Also sie hat offensichtlich eine Brust-OP gehabt und kurzfristig eine Nachbestrahlung, aber das ist schon 14 Jahre zurück.
Aber Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie hatten niemals eine Lymphoedema oder irgendwas, ja?
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Frau Kollegen, sind Sie bereit?
Ja, ja.
Kann weitergehen. Alles klar.
Wenn Sie möchten, wir können weitermachen.
Okay, ha ha. Guten Tag, Frau Oberärztin.
Ja, hallo, guten Tag.
Hallo, ich habe heute eine neue Patientin. Ich möchte Ihnen die Patientin gerne vorstellen, wenn Sie Zeit haben.
Ja, natürlich. Wen haben Sie gesehen?
Magda Lena Schmidt ist unsere Patientin. Sie ist 56 Jahre alt, ist 1,68 m groß und wiegt 79 kg.
Sie kommt zu uns mit seit vier Tagen plötzlich aufgetretenen Schmerzen am rechten Oberarm vor.
Begleitend hat sie in diesem Bereich im Oberarm auch eine Ödeme, ein Druckgefühl und die Finger sind auch verschwollen und an den Fingern hat sie auch Ödeme und ein Spannungsgefühl.
Ein Spannungsgefühl, ja.
Spannungsgefühl hat sie erwähnt. Druckgefühl, Spannungsgefühl und die Beschwerden sind dauerhaft, sind progredient und sind plötzlich aufgetreten.
Sie sind ständig da. Der Schmerzkraft herrscht.
Das war der Dummf, ein druckender Schmerz und auf einer Schmerzkala hat sie die Schmerzen 6 von 10 bewertet und sie hat nichts eingenommen.
Sie war nicht vor uns beim Arzt. Sie ist zum ersten Mal zu uns gekommen und hatte keine anderen Arzt. Alle diese Beschwerden sind zum ersten Mal aufgetreten.
Die Fragen nach Fieber, Fieber ist wichtig, nach Fieber nach Schweißschulfrost wurden verneint. Also insgesamt in der vegetativen Anemnese.
Die vegetativen Anemnese ist unauffällig bis auf Beschwerde bedingte Insomnie.
Ah ja, klar.
Sonst war es unauffällig, die vegetativen Anemnese.
Als Vollkrankung leidet sie an arteriöler Hypertonie seit 14 Jahren. Vor einem Jahr hat sie einen Hüfte, nein, Prothese, einen Hüftep bekommen.
Und erwähnenswert ist, dass sie vor 14 Jahren wegen Mamas her eine Brust-OP hatte.
Welcher Seite?
Das habe ich nicht gepfarrt glaube ich. Die Seite habe ich nicht gepfarrt.
Okay.
Sie hat noch eine Polenallergie, deswegen nimmt sie bei Bedarf Citricin ein.
Und als Vollkrankung habe ich noch etwas vergessen. Sie leidet an Hyperkolestinämie seit 14 Jahren.
Und die Medikamente sind das. Op hatte sie, die Brust-OP gehabt.
Und die Hüfte?
Ah ja, die Hüfte. Sie ist nicht Raucherin, sie hat nie geraucht. Sie trinkt gelegentlich Wein und Bier. Der Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese ist der Vater unter 60 Jahren an Myokratinfarkt verstorben. Die Mutter leidet an arteriöler Hypertonie.
Er hatte einen Bruder, aber der ist auch an Myokratinfarkt gestorben. Die Schwester hatte vor einem Jahr einen Mamas her gehabt.
Sie wurde auch operiert wegen Mamas her. Als Sport treibt sie manchmal Fahrrad. Reiseanamnese wurde verneint. Der Impfstatus war wahrscheinlich vollständig.
Die Grippe-Impfung und die Covid-Impfung sind erfolgt. Sie ist verheiratet, wohne mit ihrem Ehemann. Sie hat zwei gesunde Kinder. Sie ist schon erwachsen.
Als Beruf ist sie eine Reisebüroverkehrskauffrau.
Die Diagnostik der anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten. Das kann vielleicht ein Lymphödem sein. Aber bei Lymphödem erwarten wir keine Schmerzen.
Das könnte auch sein.
Eine Venenthrombose. Eine Venenthrenzündung.
Was machen Sie Diagnostik mit der Patientin?
Was mache ich? Erst muss ich die Patientin körperlich untersuchen. Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Worauf achte ich? Erst mal inspeziere ich.
Ich achte darauf, ob es auch die Farbeveränderungen im ganzen Körper gibt.
Ob es auch die Empathien gibt im Serikalbereich, Axelalbereich, Inguinalbereich.
Ob es die Wärme, die Hautwärme gibt.
Ich muss das mit dem anderen Arm vergleichen. Den Umfang muss ich messen.
Die Wärme muss ich vergleichen. Am Arm auch noch Sensibilität untersuchen.
Eine Nudelungsuntersuchung wäre auch sinnvoll in diesem Fall. Ob es Palästhesien oder Palästhesien gibt.
Und wonach müssen Sie noch gucken?
Das wäre auch sinnvoll, ja. Die Motorikfunktion.
Die hat ja gesagt, durch die Spalung ist sie eingeschränkt. Aber ich möchte mich darauf beziehen, dass einer der Kollegen gefragt hat, ob es einen Insektenstich gab.
Also wonach müssen Sie gucken?
Ob es eine Stichstelle gibt.
Sie haben auch selber gefragt, ob es Verletzungen gab oder ob sie einen Zeckenbiss hatte. Sie hat das verneint, aber Sie müssen trotzdem überprüfen, ob Sie an dem Arm irgendwas sehen.
Sie können ja drum herum gucken, wo sie vielleicht selber nicht hingucken kann.
Da muss man auf alle Fälle überprüfen, ob man an dem Arm eine kleine Wunde oder einen Hautriss oder eine Stichstelle sieht.
Was machen Sie weiter diagnostisch?
Da muss ich Blut abnehmen.
Auf welchem Arm nehmen Sie Blut ab?
Den anderen Arm.
Ja, gut, klar.
Was machen Sie noch? Was lassen Sie sich bestimmen?
Ja, Blutbild, Hemoglobinwerte, Entzündungsparameter, CRP, BSG, ob es Lykositos gibt im Blut, das ist wichtig.
Was noch?
Vielleicht Murmalker für die Mama.
Ja, die ist gut.
Was müssen wir noch machen, wenn wir die Tiefe am Bein drum holen?
Auf alle Fälle.
Gut.
Und Geringsparameter.
Nach dem Blut abnehmen könnte ich eine Dopplersonographie an dieser Stelle.
Das wäre sinnvoll für TvT.
Sehr gut.
Was noch?
Ja, das ist es eigentlich schon.
Und wenn sich jetzt bestätigt, was haben wir gesagt? Sie haben als erstes gesagt Lymphedelm, oder?
Ja, Lymphedelm.
Was war Ihre Hauptdiagnose?
Ich denke, die Hauptdiagnose ist TvT.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das im Arm auch so geht. Wir wissen ja, dass das immer am Bein erwartet wird.
Aber es könnte ja auch oben auftreten.
Wenn sich jetzt bestätigt, dass sie eine Armwindtrombose hat, was wäre dann die Therapie?
Dann natürlich Antikoagulation und Hochlagerung.
Bei Hochlagerung, Petruet-Hochlagerung, Gleichhäperlisation, Antikoagulation.
Was noch?
Einen wichtigen Punkt haben Sie noch vergessen.
Bei TvT.
Was würden Sie beim Bein machen?
Beim Bein hochlagern und beim Bein...
Nein, ich muss das...
Also das ist doch im Arm. Was muss ich am Bein machen?
Ja, da kommt...
Kompressionsstrümpfe.
Ja, sehr gut.
Armstrumpf gibt es ja auch.
Es gibt auch einen Armstrumpf.
Und wenn der noch nicht angepasst werden kann, weil der Arm noch zu sehr geschwollen ist, muss man halt bandagieren.
Das war diese Bewegung.
Ja, ja, ja.
Gut, ja.
Gut, das wäre für den Fall. Und wie lange müsste man Heparin, bzw. dann ja umstellen auf Makuma oder irgendein modernes Antikoagulanz, wie lange müsste man das machen?
Mindestens sechs Monate.
Ja, genau, richtig.
Ja.
Und Bewegung ist wichtig. Aber nicht am Anfang. Ja, später also.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu den anderen Sachen. Was eben alles noch dahinterstecken könnte, da haben Sie eigentlich ja schon viel gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt, es könnte, also man sollte überprüfen, ob die ein Rezitiv ihres Mammakassinons hat.
Das wäre eine wichtige Kontrolluntersuchung.
Da sind Sie im Labor schon drin gewesen. Sie haben die Lymphknotenstationen erwähnt.
Und da sollte man sicherlich auch diese entsprechende Brust nochmal abtasten, ob man da irgendwas wie im Ultraschall das machen kann.
Und gegebenenfalls natürlich weitere Tumordiagnostik bzw. auch Bildgebung. Klar.
Das könnte nämlich sein, dass die einfach auch nach vielen Jahren mit einmal eine Rekranz bekommt und sich das äußert, eben in dieser Armschwellung, in dieser Armwindtrombose.
Wäre nicht das erste Mal. Ja. Und der Alternativ könnte es auch sein, das war nämlich eine interessante Frage, fand ich spannend, dass jemand eben gesagt hat,
hatten Sie ein Lymphedem? Und darauf kommen oft die Leute gar nicht, dass Patientinnen nach Brust-OP auch nach vielen Jahren noch ein Lymphedem entwickeln können.
Ja. Und zwar genau, was der Kollege auch gesagt hat, haben Sie sich besonders angestrengt, haben Sie mit dem Arm irgendwas Schweres gemacht.
Die ersten paar Jahre ist man noch sehr vorsichtig und schon den Arm und macht nichts damit. Und irgendwann denkt man, ja, ist ja alles gut,
weil ja waren alle Befunde in Ordnung und dann denkt man nicht mehr dran. Und dann belastet man halt übernormal.
Und da kann es tatsächlich passieren, dass sich dann nach Jahren nochmal ein Lymphedem entwickelt. Das ist ganz dumm.
Und natürlich eben auch, wobei dafür sprachen eigentlich viele Angaben der Patientinnen nicht.
Ein Erysipel, dafür fehlt ja eigentlich dieses Kalviergefühl, dafür fehlt die Erdnusetemperatur, dafür wäre die anders drauf.
Ja, ich habe gedacht, also tiefe Trombose, das muss immer unten sein, aber nein, das war heute ein sehr guter Fall. Vielen Dank.
Ja, es könnte eben auch gar nicht eine richtige Trombose, sondern nur eine Venenentzündung sein. Auch das kann es sein, eine Phlebitis.
Es ist tatsächlich ein Mainzer Fall und ich finde den auch sehr schön. Und ich weiß nicht, inzwischen habe ich lange glaube ich nicht gemacht den Fall
und habe es auch vielleicht noch nicht so oft erzählt, dass ich selber als Sekretärin gearbeitet habe, bis vor sechs Jahren jetzt inzwischen schon,
in einer gefäßt chirurgischen Ambulanz und wir hatten speziell Lymphpatienten. Und deswegen ist mir dieser Lymph halt immer so, ja nicht der mir, immer am Herzen.
Weil das so etwas ist, wo viele nicht dran denken. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das nur in Deutschland so ist, aber ich habe immer das Gefühl,
dass man den Frauen nach Brust-OP das nicht so richtig sagt, dass das passieren kann und wie sie sich dann verhalten sollen.
Die sind immer überrascht dann, oh jetzt habe ich was, das habe ich vorher nicht gehabt, woher kommt denn das?
Und das ist ja eigentlich so eine klassische Komplikation oder Nachfolge. Und man kann ja ganz viel tun, man kann die Befunde so gut verbessern.
Durch konsequente Therapie. Die ist natürlich lästig, weil Armstrumpftragen ist blöd.
Und da muss man tatsächlich noch eine wichtige Sache sagen, wenn es eine Klebitis oder eine Tibivinen-Trombose ist, ist es ein rundgestrickter Strumpf.
Wenn es ein Lymphedäm ist, muss es ein flachgestrickter Strumpf sein. Das sind andere Strumpfe.
Und die müssen im Sanitätshaus dann maßgenau eben ausgemessen werden. Das ist nochmal wichtig.
Gut, ja. Mir hat wieder, also ja, ich muss Ihnen jetzt noch ein bisschen Rückmeldung geben. Sie wissen ganz genau, Ihr Deutsch ist ausgezeichnet.
Was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, das ist vielleicht mir besonders aufgefallen dadurch, dass wir uns nicht sehen konnten,
ist mir aufgefallen, dass Sie zwischendurch mal so, als ob Sie in Ihr Unterlagenblätter, was muss ich denn jetzt noch fragen?
Das ist so ein bisschen umständlich Klang. Und so, dass Sie immer, ja jetzt muss ich doch nochmal nachgucken, was habe ich denn noch vergessen?
Das wirkt nicht so sehr souverän. Versuchen Sie da nochmal so eine gewisse Kontinuität reinzukriegen, dass Sie sagen, das alles muss ich fragen.
Und ja, das fand ich auch gut, wie Sie reagiert haben, dass Sie gesagt haben, ja das mag Ihnen komisch erscheinen, dass ich das alles frage,
aber das ist wichtig für unsere Diagnosistellung. Die war ja so ein bisschen umständlich. Was soll ich mit dem Herz haben?
Was soll ich mit dem Bauch haben? Was auch immer mit der Verdauung? Ich bin neben einem Arm hier, ja.
Und das ist ja eigentlich so eine typische Situation, dass Patienten manchmal eben dann ja nicht verstehen, warum sie das nun auch noch wissen wollen.
Ja, das ist doch eine blöde Frage jetzt. Wobei ich selber ehrlich denke, wenn also jemand wirklich mit einer schweren Traumaverletzung kommt,
dann ist die Frage nach Nachtschweiß und was weiß ich nicht so richtig zielführend.
Aber wir müssen das schon fragen. Ich weiß, dass Sie das fragen müssen in diesen Simulationen, ja, ist mir schon klar.
Es ist einfach so, dass wir keine echte Situation haben. Darüber müssen wir uns immer im Klaren sein.
Ja, normalerweise hätten Sie alle Daten des Patienten vor sich das erste Mal gegenüber sitzen.
Und Sie sehen den und können auch sagen, ob der blass oder knallrot ist oder was auch immer.
Ob der krank aussieht oder ob der eigentlich fit und gesund aussieht.
Und Sie sehen ja auch, was ich im Zweifelsfall, diesen Arm hier, ob der dick oder nicht dick ist und ob ich den festhalte oder nicht.
Wir haben ja eine unnatürliche Situation. Das ist eben nur eine Simulation.
Aber ich finde es wieder klasse, dass so viele Leute mitgearbeitet haben und spannende Fragen gestellt haben.
Augenblick. Jetzt muss ich eine Sache... Ja, bei Ihren Deutsch-Sachen...
... paar Sachen habe ich verbessert. So gleich, direkt.
Witzig fand ich. Sie haben eine Kombination gemacht. Sie kommt mit und sie stellt sich vor.
Sie kommt mit Schmerzen im rechten Oberarm. Pipa-Po, noch irgendwie so zunehmende Schmerzen.
Den ersten Satz für Vorstellungen, das kann ich nicht machen. Das geht mir immer schwer.
Ja, aber Sie haben etwas Richtiges gemacht. Wenn Sie sagen, Sie kommen mit,
dann muss man ja nur sagen, Sie kommen mit Schmerzen im Arm und beschreibt auch eine Schwellung und Rötung und Überwärmung.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, Sie kommt mit den ganzen Reihen vor.
Sie stellt sich mit den und den vor. Aber ich finde, Sie kommt mit ist eine sehr gute Formulierung,
weil Sie da dieses trennbare Verb praktisch ausmerzen und das nicht benutzen müssen.
Gut. Und auch eine Winzigkeit, aber weil Sie ja eigentlich perfekt Deutsch sprechen.
Als Beruf ist sie Reiseverkehrsfrau. Nee, wir sagen von Beruf. Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Von Beruf, oh ja.
Oder man kann sagen, als Beruf gibt sie Reiseverkehrsfrau, Kaufrau an.
Von Beruf ist sie oder?
Von Beruf ist sie. Ist sie Reiseverkehrsfrau.
Das sage ich immer falsch. Ich glaube, das habe ich damals falsch.
Es ist ja charmant. Solche Sachen sind ja charmant. Es ist ja nett.
Aber da Sie wirklich auf so einem hohen Niveau Deutsch sprechen und so Kleinigkeiten falsch sagen,
da denke ich mal, kann man das korrigieren, das ist doch gut.
Und ich mache selber auch M, das muss ich mal sagen. Ich weiß, dass ich das auch mache.
Können Sie den ersten Satz nochmal sagen für die Vorstellung an diesen Fall?
Ja, also die Patientin kommt heute mit einer seit drei Tagen bestehenden Schwellung im rechten Arm,
die sich auch im Laufe der Zeit verstärkt. Also könnte man das mal prognolieren.
Sie beschreibt moderate Schmerzen, Rötungen und Überfermungen.
Nur der erste Satz.
Sie kommt mit oder stellt sich bei uns mit Schmerzen und Schwellung im rechten Oberarm vor?
Wenn ich stellte, dann geht es mit vor weiter.
Dann geht es mit vor weiter.
Aber je mehr Beschreibungen man da reinbringt, desto eher vergisst man das vor am Ende.
Und dann wird es auch irgendwann komisch.
Ja, genau. Können wir das vor auch am Anfang benutzen?
Ja, sie stellt sich bei uns vor mit Schmerzen.
Das ist auch einfacher.
Das ist tatsächlich, eigentlich natürlich grammatikalisch nicht richtig,
ist aber eine im Deutschen durchaus angewandte Formulierung.
Ich habe das jetzt kürzlich, genau in einem C1-Buch, habe ich das irgendwo gelesen als Beispiel,
dass so eine Form der Aufweichung von Grammatikregeln ist,
dass wir eben in der Alltagssprache uns ein paar Ungenauigkeiten erlauben, die jetzt nicht tragisch sind.
Gut, ja.
Ich denke mal, es war eine gute Anamnese, eine schöne Wiedergabe.